with 70 million Catholics in America so
whoever the Pope is is incredibly
important I believe this is the fourth
most populous Catholic country in the
world so to have the head of the
Catholic Church here it's just always so
significant to people in their faith
journey in America within the Catholic
Church I would say that under normal
circumstances I think Pope Francis is
extraordinary I don't know anybody who
is not moved by his example and his
spirit and the way he's leading the
church there are ideological differences
with him I suppose on different areas of
the spectrum and I'm not wading into
Church doctrine here but I love his
spirit and I love his example and I love
his humility and I love his voice of
conscience in the world I'm really moved
by the the practice of washing someone
else's feet you know in the Gospels when
Jesus washes Peters feet he looks at him
almost with kind of horror and
trepidation like you know why are you
doing that you know and Jesus says to
him essentially when you learn the
importance of doing this you'll
understand why it's so important it is
an act of humility and to understand
that the basis of humanity is serving
each other having compassion for each
other and understanding that we're all
in this together so I love his spirit
and I love his example
you